never less talk money we always talk to
work I was playing the credit card
shuffle game I was shuffling no payments
doing all this stuff and realized that
was one of the biggest stressors in my
life that I couldn't do this anymore
everything in our society seems to be
pitched at spending more and being okay
with being in debt I was really starting
to steps back even as all this that
stacked up I never thought but obviously
this easy debt is the problem so we had
numerous fights because it wasn't easy
my passion is a direct result of all of
the pain and all of the struggle and all
of the failures I knew that I wanted
something to change for me the hardest
part was just changing my mindset and
making the important things more
important and the less important
material things less important we were
listening to your show and you know what
this is like motivating and flipped a
switch for us for me that was like when
I needed to do something about it we got
the Total Money Makeover book I think we
had the book from the library that was
the beginning of our journey was the
book we went to finally what FPU after
about a year and I decided it was time
to transform this because I have what it
takes and now's the time to do it we
were going to do this no matter what we
talked it over and says hey if we really
buckle down there's there's a small
chance we could pay these debts off this
year I was willing to do whatever it
took to keep us out of debt we needed to
kind of communicate better in the
financial department she's a great
homemaker a very thrifty very organized
and a real encouragement to me to work
hard and it started turning into a
little bit of
Challenge I'm working at 12:00 midnight
this is nice you know second or third
job today
those little victories are seriously
like we totally celebrate in this we
know the tainted them a tree and make
our son's life even better than ours
is the coolest thing ever but I think
since we were working so hard when we
did have time as a family we really made
it count to me.they kids being there
with them I'm getting choked out so I
that's just thinking about it it gave me
such encouragement to know that it
wasn't just the storms that they would
remember but coming through the storms
and being on the other side financial
peace is not just a name and so I came
overseas we're gonna do this it's gonna
be hard no one said it was gonna be easy
tackling this financial piece looked to
me like the key I remember how it felt
like we were sacrificing everything when
we first started
and we've given more than we ever
imagined we want to continue that legacy
that's really the most exciting thing
for me taking control of my finances
was really a turning point to allow me
to take control of everything in my
world it's something we kind of done
without communication we don't make any
excuses to why we can't reach our goals
but weird way out there still the family
tree is changing the storms are gonna
come and how are you going to deal with
that
you